you next you ready oh yeah
it will kill the ultimate forged and
fired matchup you are the forest and
fire Champion two Champion plays in a
deadly weapon Showdown it will kill 20
blades 20 Champions you decide the
winner forged in fire Madness
[Music]
the zande spear
my name is Drew Goodson I'm 18 years old
and I study mechanical engineering at
Louisiana Tech I've noticed that Doug
liked recurve blades I don't know if
that's how he likes his women curvy but
my grandmother has totally got a crush
on him especially when he says it will
kill one of the deadliest weapons used
by the zande tribes of central Africa
the zande spear was used for fighting as
well as for hunting known throughout
history as conquering Warriors the zande
exhibited unmatched skills on the
battlefield the fixed to a wooden shaft
the spear was suitable for throwing and
attacking from long distances but his
thrusting ability made it just as
effective as a close combat weapon the
sharp upper and lower tines multiple
spikes inflicted deadly wounds both upon
entry and exit from the victim's body
the zande's lethal use of the spear can
be seen highlighted in the game
Deadliest Warrior
the boar spear my name is Alan Newberry
I've been making knives for about nine
years I am a stay-at-home dad slash
Custom Knife maker developed as early as
700 A.D in Europe the boar spear was
forged for both combat and hunting known
at the time as a bar spare the weapon
was about five to six feet long and
featured a pair of lugs below the
leaf-shaped blade when hunting the lugs
would stop a speared bore from running
up the length of the weapon and
attacking the user
in combat the lugs could be used to hook
and pull away enemy Shields
the spear could be decorated with some
featuring finally engraved scenes of
Hunts on the first season of Game of
Thrones king Robert Baratheon carried a
boar spear on his final boar hunt
what I want to do today is get the blade
forged out so I've got a piece of 1080
for steel it's not quite enough for what
I want to do I'm gonna have to do some
creative thinking to make it work I've
taken that 20 inch piece of Steel and
just by doing that much
drawn it to over 21 inches I want to get
the spearhead completely forged today
got marks where I'm going to cut into
and stop I'm going to bend those out and
draw them back that's a good plan I'm
going to forge weld two pieces of Steel
on either end of this because it's
getting thin and I don't want this to
bend in a slightest I know in the
testing they're going to abuse my weapon
but I'm not worried about it because I
know what I'm doing
[Music]
now
one
I'm sitting here waiting for a ping or a
pop or something scraping but I don't
care it just a nice little sizzle
I've got three hours to get this done
and I've allowed the entire day to
finishing the shaft of the spear fitting
sharpening nothing big
the tank doesn't quite fit in the shaft
why why is this happening I'm almost
over the height requirement
uh okay crisis averted I'm all good
I don't even know what I feel right now
okay
that's a panic get get off yep yep gonna
chill out
okay
and I'm excited to have just made it
this far and get to actually do the
entire challenge the socket is the part
of the spear that you insert the shaft
into I haven't ever made a socket before
and so it's a little nerve-wracking but
I'm excited to try it I'm gonna start
forming a nice thin triangular shape and
then I'm going to Pam it around into a
circular cone shape now I have to be
super careful because the metal in the
socket is very thin if this metal gets
too hot it's going to just kind of belt
and crumble away all right it looks like
a socket hopefully it'll stay looking
like a socket time's really crunched I'm
just really behind the eight ball
getting the lugs on the spear shaft
blower has just died my Forge burnt out
the engine died now I'm gonna have to
find a replacement
there's still a lot to do I'm literally
running to the store to buy another
blower things just really are not going
my way today
my Forge burnt out the engine died had
to run out and lose time I had to get a
new motor with all these setbacks I'm
starting to be a bit worried
with the way things have been going
today we're coming down to the wire on
time here it could come back to bite me
well my vision for this is to have a
nice dark pole we'll heat it up with the
torch until it turns black and then I'm
going to rub some beeswax from my own
bees the beeswax and it'll kind of melt
in there and treat the wood and give it
a nice Sheen
time's still rolling I'm going to need
to use every minute to get this thing
looking great
I have just sharpened the bore spear I'm
thinking it's time for a little test
before I put it on the pole my kids made
this great bore I'm ready to see this
boar spear cut slice and stab
feels good to me I'm ready to see what
the judges have planned
leadsmiths I will take your Sunday Spear
and deliver killing blows on this
ballistic study Drew you're up first you
ready let's make those intestines out
testings all right let's do that I like
that
[Music]
right now I'm about to hear Doug say it
will heal and that's the only thing I'm
here for
to help you out today please welcome
back RJ markaida he will have the
pleasure of wielding your zombie spear
[Music]
right drew it feels very good in the
hand it lacerates deep when we thrust us
into the chest cavity Into the Heart on
its way out not only does it take some
skin with it but it also took out some
ribs your times right here from the side
entry the spear went all the way through
and on its way out it took everything
that was in its path
but there is one issue as you can see
your tip right here broke off
but other than that this is a weapon
that is deadly and it will kill thank
you
see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver lethal
blows to this wild boar carcass
Alan you're next you ready oh yeah let's
do this
[Music]
well Alan let's talk about your blade on
the thrust it penetrated all the way
through on the laceration on one side of
your Edge boy wow it almost sliced all
the way through
on your other Edge it lacerated through
the spine
this piercer will kill all right
say hello to my little friend here
today we're going to test the overall
strength and construction of your zande
Spears by well we're going to fire him
out of this cannon into this wood block
wall now I'm not concerned about what
your Spears do to the wall I want to see
how well your Spears survive the wall
Drew you're up first are you ready no
well we're gonna do it anyway let's do
it
foreign
really well Drew
despite the fact that you did lose a
little bit of your tip in the kill test
didn't have any effect going into that
block wall matter of fact you sunk all
the way down here very impressive your
shaft is fine nothing loosened up
nothing cracked your spear head is still
solid overall
survives very good thank you
crazy test
fun test thrilled to see it go down
I just can't wait we'll see how deep it
penetrates how well it holds up Alan
you're up
in three
two
one
[Music]
all right Alan that buried itself quite
nicely went into about there again about
four inches deep like the leaf shape on
this I like the fact that you hand
hammered the socket I was kind of
worried when I put this in our machine
that's like warp in your shaft there
would bind up
but not a problem
good job thank you now it's your turn
which weapon will you choose forged in
fire Madness